muscle company asks how do you generate
novel ideas and an overpopulated
seemingly steel industry the fitness
industry for example the muscle company
I kind of like saying that the muscle
company I always find the best way to
attack an industry that you're in and is
stale and you want to innovate by
spending zero time in it one little fun
fact that most people don't know is I
spent an awful uh excuse me an extreme
lack of time within the wine industry
and within the agency in the stream I
don't think I've ever been I've been to
like six other agencies in my life
because the readings there I know
nothing about it I read nothing about
other agencies that ad age spend no time
asking my senior people about what they
did at other agencies when I was in the
wine business everyone's like you should
go check out this store in Dallas
they're doing X I'm like I don't give a
crap for me the way I've always been
innovative is lack of education and I'm
not joking I tend to stay within myself
and what comes natural and to I look to
other industries so if i were you i'd be
paying attention to what's happening in
the food industry or you know in the
rock climbing industry or things
completely left field like hip-hop or
sports or just stuff that has nothing to
do with your industry because the best
way to stay within the zone and not
innovate is pay attention to everybody
else because they're doing the same crap
20 Pratt wait subscribe I need
subscriptions because I can't push this
many right hooks in social